[Music]  hi drew i'm really excited to pitch this  for cookbook club  it is  hedy mckinnon's to asia with love it  reminds me of a lot of foods that i grew  up with that were very familiar i think  hedy really does a wonderful job about  breaking down flavors and making the  food very accessible to home cooks two  very special recipes that i wanted to  flag for people the first one is a spicy  sesame tantanmen ramen it is delicious  it's spicy it's rich it's savory it's  super comforting make your own dumpling  wrappers this is kind of a crowd  activity it's very simple we love hedy  mckinnon drew i know you do too to asia  with love my cookbook club  recommendation  [Music]  you